[Musique]
sensation sensation le mag
bonjour à tous bienvenue sur sensation
en association avec TV 78 je suis
aujourd'hui avec Pauline vinocourt
Lefebvre vice-présidente du département
des Yvelines délégués à la ruralité de
l'agriculture l'alimentation les
circuits courbes bonjour bonjour en
février dernier le département des
Yvelines a officialisé sa participation
dans la case Thoiry bioénergie
pouvez-vous nous présenter justement
Thoiry bioénergie et pourquoi le
département a décidé de se joindre à la
société alors SOS la SAS pardon Thoiry
bioénergie est une unité de
méthanisation qui récupère notamment les
déchets organiques du ZooParc de Thoiry
et le département a décidé de s'y
engager alors d'une part parce que on a
engagé une réflexion et des actions sur
la façon dont on pouvait s'impliquer
dans ce type d'énergie je pense
notamment aux projets de géothermie qui
est à Rocquencourt dans lequel le
département participe aussi et
et le et toi ribio énergie avait
besoin d'un d'un soutien financier et
donc prendre une participation dans la
société était un moyen de répondre à ce
besoin dans le montant de l'opération
s'élève à 2 millions d'euros vous
souhaitez accompagner pérenniser la
méthanisation des déchets du zoo Thoiry
en quelques mots qu'est-ce que la
méthanisation
la méthanisation c'est le principe de la
digestion en fait
c'est à dire qu'on alimente les
méthaniseurs en déchets organiques en
bio des chefs peut être les déchets des
cantines scolaires là ce sont les les
fumiers
au fumier des animaux ça peut être des
déchets verts tout type de déchets
organiques des déchets agricoles parfois
aussi
on y est dans une machine qui les digère
qui produit du gaz tout à fait comme
notre digestion sauf que le gaz est
réutilisé pour produire de l'énergie
alors pourquoi accompagner justement
Thoiry Thoiry bioénergie est-ce que les
autres Thoiry finalement et de base
polluants ou en tout cas est-ce que
c'est un grand comment dire un grand
producteur finalement de ce gaz qui peut
devenir du gaz vert
alors le zoo Thoiry est pas poli en fait
c'est-à-dire que la méthanisation c'est
pas une entreprise de dépollution c'est
une entreprise de réutilisation de
certains déchets on pourrait très bien
dire que les fumiers on va les dépendre
dans les parcelles agricoles alentour là
le but c'est de produire de l'énergie
avec alors pourquoi l'accompagner comme
je vous le disais tout à l'heure on est
engagé dans cette dans cette démarche là
à travers plusieurs types de projets et
ça permet de produire une énergie locale
et une énergie en circuit court
en circuit court et de recycler enfin de
réutiliser les déchets alors ce que j'ai
oublié de dire c'est qu'après ce
processus de digestion reste dans les
méthaniseurs ce qu'on appelle un
digestat qui est le jus de digestion et
qui est quelque chose qu'on peut aussi
aller
étendre dans les parcelles agricoles
donc le méthaniseur vous vous l'avez
évoqué
il y aura aussi les déchets verts des
collectivités voisines qui sera seront
sont associés
aux collectivités pardon voisine de de
récupérer leurs déchets verts est-ce que
c'est du coup une production plus grande
et donc une énergie plus importante que
vous allez développer c'est surtout
parce que pour digérer le méthaniseur a
besoin de manger donc il faut
l'alimenter en matière organique et
c'est une façon
de récupérer les déchets verts des
habitants des de 9 communes autour du
méthaniseur on a la chance sur le
territoire de coeur indivine d'avoir un
ramassage des déchets verts qui sont
tous les déchets de jardinage en fait de
toutes les feuilles les branches etc et
qui sont susceptibles de de passer dans
le dans un méthaniseur et ce service
est-ce que ça veut dire qu'il va coûter
moins cher aux collectivités et aux
habitants puisqu'il est de proximité
puisqu'il est local
alors pour être tout à fait transparente
avec vous je ne sais pas comment et
valoriser le gaz qui sort ce que je sais
c'est qu'il alimente des communes
alentours je sais pas à quel tarif et on
va parler plus en détail de la politique
du département sur la thématique de
l'environnement en 2022 vous êtes engagé
dans une politique volontariste de la
transition énergétique qu'est-ce que ça
signifie
ça veut dire
qu'on est attentif à ce que les projets
qu'on met en oeuvre soit les plus
vertueux possible d'un point de vue
environnemental le moins producteur de
CO2 par exemple je pense au la première
annonce qui avait été faite c'est la
construction de 15 collèges en
matière bio sourcée et donc à faible
émission énergétique et des collèges qui
soient plus des passoires énergétiques
voilà on le fait parce que alors ça
coûte plus cher ça coûte même beaucoup
plus cher mais
ça va quand même dans le sens de ce qui
doit être fait aujourd'hui et de la
façon dont on se doit de construire
aujourd'hui et peut-être en tant que
collectivité de montrer l'exemple la
méthanisation justement rentre de toute
façon dans cette volonté justement
d'être plus plus vertueux oui oui la
méthanisation enfin c'est vraiment une
façon de de produire de l'énergie des
carbonées en fait c'est vachement
intéressant c'est très intéressant
pardon c'est il y a un autre projet de
méta dans les Yvelines alors on n'a pas
participé au projet mais on est parti
prenante parce que il évacue les déchets
alimentaires de nos collèges c'est un
méthaniseur qui a carrière sous Poissy
qui est le méthaniseur triom et c'est
pareil c'est une petite unité de
digestion dans dans laquelle partent
tous les déchets des cantines du
département
qui sont qui sont transformés en biogaz
qui repartent soit dans le réseau soit
alimente les camions qui vont chercher
les déchets ou déposer le digestat dans
les champs donc on est sur des logiques
vraiment de circuits courts presque
d'autonomie en matière de production
d'énergie et
à l'échelle de territoires et c'est
vraiment intéressant et qu'est-ce que
les Yvelinois justement ont y gagner à
travers cette cet engagement de la
transition écologique du département
on leur offre des services qui répondent
à ces enjeux contemporains qui sont
quand même des enjeux importants sur des
thématiques extrêmement anxiogènes
notamment pour les plus jeunes
d'ailleurs pour qui c'est encore plus un
sujet
que pour les plus anciens et donc on
leur donne la possibilité de grandir et
d'apprendre dans des collages qui
répondent à ces exigences d'utiliser une
énergie qui répondent à ces exigences
également donc ils ont ils ont pas mal à
y gagner il y a de toute façon une
demande des citoyens en tout cas des
yvelinois dans votre cas attendre vers
justement des énergies plus vertueuses
je pense qu'il y a des attentes de toute
la société enfin à moins de pas avoir
pas écouter ce qui se passe on voit bien
qu'il y a un réel enjeu et une réelle
nécessité de
modifier certains de nos comportements
et comment par exemple le Département
soutient les projets des collectivités
sur la thématique de
[Musique]
plus dans les assiettes des collégiens
ça peut être un levier c'est pas c'est
pas des quantités colossales qu'il faut
pour alimenter tous nos collégiens sur
toute l'année scolaire mais ça peut
avoir un effet de levier et ces assises
ont pour but de réfléchir avec d'autres
acteurs que nous et nos collègues et les
représentants de nos collèges pour voir
quels sont les leviers qu'on pourrait
mettre en place pour pour que nos
producteurs puissent plus sereinement
diffuser leur production
les collèges les collégiens pour pour
les circuits courts donc pour finalement
de la nourriture locale de la production
locale et ce qui a aussi par là une
volonté de sensibilisation à ce public
aux produits locaux
oui et la sensibilisation elle porte
parfois sur les types de produits
concernant les cantines c'est-à-dire que
quand on est en local
je pense par exemple à la viande si on
si on décidait de ne consommer demain
que de la viande locale ça aurait un
coût supplémentaire donc pour le
compenser on peut très bien imaginer
avoir d'autres sources de protéines et
notamment des légumineuses là il y a un
vrai enjeu d'éducation pour faire manger
les légumineuses
à nos à nos enfants donc il y a aussi
cette réflexion là qui est menée sur
comment cuisiner les plats les les
produits locaux qui sont pas des
produits transformés et comment les
faire les faire avaler sans vouloir être
les faire avaler au collégien qui qui
ont pas forcément les mêmes habitudes
chez eux et le département peut être un
levier pour ça pour les consommateurs ça
peut passer par les enfants pour se
diffuser après l'enjeu évidemment de
soutenir nos agriculteurs nos
producteurs et de maintenir chez nous
dans un département qui a pas toujours
l'image d'un département agricole et
pourtant qui est un département agricole
de maintenir une agriculture dynamique
et innovante on pourra justement en
parler dans d'autres émissions au cours
de l'année merci beaucoup Pauline
vinocourt Lefebvre d'avoir été avec nous
sur sensation pour plus d'informations
peut se rendre sur le site yvelines.fr
et pour revoir ou réécouter cette
émission rendez-vous sur notre site et
notre application radio sensation
[Musique]